[Music]
on today's show we talk about a lot of
heavy topics not appropriate for kids so
please watch out for the little ears
in the room on today's show we talk
about psychotropic medications
and a mom calls talks about the shame
she's feeling for having to go on
anxiety medication
we also talked to a young husband who
loves his wife
and is trying to navigate her broken
relationship with his mother-in-law
and we talk to a young girl who opens up
about the abuse she suffered at the
hands of her brother and how her mom
just turned her head it's a heavy show
stay tuned
hey what's going on this is jon and this
is the dr
john deloney show a live show where we
show up
and walk alongside people who are trying
to figure out their life
trying to figure out what to eat how to
love how to move
are they going to a job that they hate
every day working for people that
are dishonest or disinterested people
learning how to be human beings again we
talk about
all of it on the show anything and
everything no matter what's going on in
your heart in your mind or your family
everyone is struggling everyone's got
joys as well
so we're all walking along together
so i'm taking your calls this show is
about you it's for you
it's by you right and we talk about
infidelity
we talk about past abuse we talk about
figuring out what's the next right thing
to do
for our husbands for our wives for our
girlfriends our boyfriends
where we go to the office every day and
we might talk about people
listen i'm gonna step into it on this
one and i don't even care because it's
driving me crazy
as many of you know i have not been a
part of social media
ever i had like a facebook account when
i was in college and then my grandpa
literally my grandpa tried like friended
me
and i was like nope i'm out and that was
years ago and so when i took this
job i had to also join the internets
and one thing i've noticed that is
driving me crazy
is the number of people who get science
and medical advice
from instagram influencers from
facebook posts
people listen the fda
a total cluster modern medicine has
many challenges and it's in need of some
major paradigm shifts
no question right what we were told
about diet and nutrition
is almost entirely wrong
almost universally incorrect modern
mental health care needs some
major paradigm shifts got it
and internet influencers who are writing
provocative one-liners
and just repeating other one-liners that
they heard from other influencers
are at best idiots and at worst
dangerous
stop getting your science stop getting
your
medical information from internet
influencers
listen to real doctors find a doctor who
will partner with you
read books by medical researchers
learn how and you can even do this you
can there's youtube
things it sounds ridiculous that i'm
telling you to go to youtube
to learn how to read science articles
find somebody
in your local community in your family
in your home
find somebody who knows somebody who
knows somebody that can teach you how to
read your own medical journals
subscribe to people who know what
they're talking about but for god's sake
stop getting
medical advice vaccination advice
doctor advice economic advice
from an internet influencer talk to
people who know what they're talking
about
good god almighty dude please
please that's all i'm going to say about
that
call us 1-844-693-3291 that's
1-844-693-3291
we're going to give you real information
actual real things that are going to
help you
in your life and here's the thing if i
don't know something
you know what i do i call experts and
here's who i define as experts
not just medical doctors and not just
medical doctor researchers
but people who are practicing and seeing
patients and who are doing research and
who are closely collaborating with those
and those who know how to read research
and those who know how to practice
things and those who are living these
things in their own lives
let me give you one quick hint i wasn't
even going to talk about this let me
give you one quick hint
years ago i realized this when i was
working in higher ed everyone who around
me
everyone that i worked with had phds
they'd studied a particular thing they'd
studied molecular biology they'd study
protein synthesis they'd study
climates they'd study water they'd study
any number of things
they'd study theology they'd study
religion they had phds and things where
they had spent years and years and years
studying these things
and if i ask somebody the question hey
what do you think about
they would give me a dissertation they'd
give me an article they would give me
here's a way to think about it here's
the way to think about it here's how
this author thinks about it here's how
that author thinks about it
and then i would notice yeah but that's
not what you're doing in your life
and so then i realized i was asking
these researchers
the wrong question not what do you think
but what do you do and so for instance
one time i was walking out of a doctor's
office she was the head of the ob gyn at
the university where i worked my wife
saw her and i was joining my wife on an
appointment
as we were leaving this woman was a
scholar a
world-class researcher she ran some
major grants and made some major
advancements in the field
and she was a practitioner and as we
were leaving i
asked her hey by the way can you spray
your kids with bug spray
with deet and she hung her head
she knew exactly what i was doing
exactly where i was going with this and
she said
yeah i do and deet's gonna kill us all
and
neurological issues and wow she rattled
it off but she said at the end of the
day
i'm more worried about west nile and i'm
more worried about mosquitoes and so
i take the easy route and i spray my
kids and then i went like this
got it because she knows more about it
she's a practitioner
she is brilliant and she told me what
she actually does
she brings her kids a bug spray before
they run out into the woods
that is the difference between reading
an internet influencer
and going straight to the source what do
you do with your kids
that's how you find out what people are
really believe
what they are really doing what they're
really putting into practice that's
where you get information
not from influencers all right so again
give me a call at 1-844-693-3291
or go to johndaloni.com show fill out
the form
and we will check it out and i know the
influencers are going to light me up say
yeah but you know what i read a
i don't care all right let's go to kelly
in philadelphia kelly
good morning how are we doing i'm good
how are you doing
i am doing to quote the great dave
ramsey better than i deserve
how can i help um so i've struggled with
anxiety for a while
um but haven't needed medication in
years i've recently started taking meds
again um to help with the increased
anxiety of
2020. and um i'm struggling with
feelings of failure and brokenness
i'm not quite sure how to navigate that
so you say you haven't taken
medication in a while when did you last
take medication
about 10 years ago tell me about the
circumstances surrounding that
um we were my husband and i um
at the time we were engaged and
moved to florida away from family and
friends
and were planning a wedding at the time
too so there was a lot of stress going
on
and saw a doctor and
they thought it was a good idea since i
had a history of depression
um as well that medication would be
the best thing for me to be on to get
through
all of the stressors and so how long did
you take medication for just to get you
through that season
um yeah i think it ended up being about
a year okay
and then what are the things you did to
help heal during that time
in addition to medication
um i guess i kept busy with you know
with my job at the time
uh socializing with friends getting out
of the house
going on weekend trips with my husband
and um just different things to keep my
mind off of
what might be going on that wasn't so
great in my life
so fast forward 10 years to right now
what what finally pushed you over the
edge and said i need to go see a doctor
again
um i mean i know we're all
in the same position with the pandemic
and um hold on hold on people are
i don't want you to compare your
situation to others
i want you just to tell your story
because your story by itself has value
and i know other people's got it worse i
got that i want you to tell me
what what happened in your life that
made you
one day open your eyes and say i gotta
go see somebody
um i i try not to watch the news
but um i have continued to go to the gym
to exercise throughout everything
and there are screens everywhere there
so you see
it's getting worse stay home don't go
anywhere don't see family for
thanksgiving
and um it was probably about two weeks
ago that
i hit rock bottom and um but what
besides
what besides the news something else
um my my mom i love her
she recently retired i get calls every
day from her
asking how are cases down where you are
are you guys okay
what you know what's going on so that
kind of triggers the
oh my gosh like this is this is getting
bad this is crazy
and um that just
you know i see her name pop up on my
caller id
and it just freaks me out because i know
we're about to talk about stuff that
gets my anxiety going
so back up a little bit do you have a
good relationship with your mom
um kind of it's not great
okay so the answer to that question is
no i can answer that for you because
you're a good human being and you're
going to say kind of so i appreciate
that about you
walk me back to when you're a teenager
how did you and your mom get along
not great um what is not great
um i wasn't really given a whole lot of
choices in
how my life was going at the time i was
required to do these certain lessons or
required to take these courses
in school so i didn't really feel like i
had a lot of
flexibility or freedom or voice in
um you know day to day choices it was
kind of
picked for me what about your dad how'd
you get along with your old man
um growing up as a teenager he and i
fought all the time but now
he is probably my favorite person in the
entire world
that's awesome he's meant more to me as
i've become a parent
i have a lot of respect for him and tell
me about your kids
i have one little boy he just turned
seven
we would have loved to have more but
he's he's
the one we were given and i'm so proud
of him he's amazing
okay so i'm gonna answer your question
in a bigger funnel than the one you
initially called me about but i will get
to your question directly
okay okay so a couple of things to note
number one anxiety and depression are on
the same trend line
they are not distinct things like a
broken ankle and cancer are
okay so they usually work in tandem
together
and one leads to the other one or one
will push you towards
feelings of one or the other okay so i
don't want you to think that you've got
all of these quote unquote things your
body has a particular way of taking care
of you
and it will usually start with an alarm
system
and it will usually start with another
alarm and then another one and it will
get louder and louder until
one of the safest most comfortable ways
of shutting those alarms off
is turning the lights off and getting
under the covers and watching netflix
or drinking or fill in the blank with
any number of numbing behaviors working
120 hours a week
the second thing is and you've probably
heard me say this 100 times i'm going to
say it a thousand times more
all anxiety is is an alarm system
and the alarms go off generally when
someone
is out of control they don't have
control over their situation
when they are disconnected or in their
body
immediate is fearful of not being safe
and so when you back me up to your life
situations
you grew up in a house where you had no
control
people didn't care what you had to say
about things they dictated to you the
way you were gonna be and what you were
gonna do then
you entered a season where you packed up
and left everyone and everything you
know
to a new adventure where you were
totally disconnected you had little to
no control you were signing up and your
husband may be incredible he may be the
greatest guy ever
but you are still hitching your wagon to
somebody else right that's a known
an unknown entity how's this thing gonna
work starting a new job
you have a history of depression and
then finally your alarms get so loud
that you go see a doctor which i'm proud
of you for going good for you
and then we reach this new place where
you've got this new moment in history
and it's not a new moment but it's new
for us
we're literally we're entering we're
leaving a or we're still in the middle
of it
um we're a couple days out from
christmas and people are still throwing
crayons at each other about the election
but you realize we don't control much
anything when it comes to democracy i
get my vote and that's it
i control very little when it comes to a
pandemic sweeping through a control very
little when it comes to the economy and
who's telling me i can work and can't
work
and then you throw on top of that
infertility challenges that you've
experienced for years
which then lead to identity questions
who am i why isn't my body working for
me
why can't i be the fill in the blank my
husband's identity is included in this
and suddenly your alarms are ringing off
the hook right
and so here's why i'm telling you these
things number one
i've experienced everything i've just
told you about
except i experienced infertility on the
other side of that
i've been crippled by anxiety myself
where my alarms are just yelling and
yelling and yelling
and it's almost always environmental in
nature
it's almost always about our ecosystem
what is the world we've created for
ourselves
and what is the world we're inheriting
right what is the world we are just
simply in
and i'm telling you that because i don't
want you to believe for one second that
you're broken
that your body's not working that it's
revolting
and that there's any sort of shame about
what's going on with you
okay okay
your body is working exactly how it was
designed to
and then you layer on top of it all of
the complexities
a mom who still loves hanging on to you
and controlling you and giving you
advice
and that's not because she's ugly or
mean or hateful
that's her way of showing you that she
loves you right
yes you've got that little boy i've got
a 10 year old and a an almost five year
old
and so you and i are both looking at
this world our kids are going to grow up
in going
what in the world right
and my alarms are going off too okay
so you did something brave and you went
to talk to a doctor
here's what anxiety medication will do
for you
it simply turns the alarms off
it shuts the alarms down it it
it it turns the nozzle down on those
things turns the knob down on those
things
and makes them not so loud anymore and
here's the important thing about taking
anxiety medication
it's only as good as the work you do
getting well when the alarms are off
right
and so what that's going to look like
for you is figuring out
boundaries with your mom maybe for the
first time
maybe it will be a conversation with her
where you say mom
you call every day and i love you i will
not talk about
the coveted numbers in my area anymore
i'm done with that conversation
it may mean that you sit with your
husband
and you say the words out loud that are
in your heart
about how many kids you wish you'd had
versus the beautiful extraordinary son
that you do have
and putting yourself putting yourself
out there being vulnerable to hearing
what your husband has to say about his
thoughts
and y'all may have never had that
conversation you may have but you may
haven't
all that to say is there are boundary
conversations there are
intimacy conversations and intimacy is
just
letting your thoughts finally be heard
it may mean that you're going to go see
a counselor and learn how to
engage and be in deep relationships with
people that are close to you
how to create new relationships which is
a skill none of us have myself included
that we've got to learn how to do those
things
but there is no shame in going to see a
doctor and saying
i need help turning these alarms off for
a season
so i can come up with some new skills
some new strategies some new moments
some new conversations some new
boundaries
they're going to help me be well moving
forward
is that fair yes
very much you are worth
an environment that supports and
sustains you
you're a good good mom kelly
and you're a good wife
and you're a good citizen
and while we're on this topic i let's
just have this conversation
people have asked me about it a lot i'll
probably end up doing an entire show on
this someday
but here's the conversations we need to
have about medication
over the past 40 years 50 years
and further back and everyone's going to
try to nitpick this thing so let's just
be open and honest and
exhale i'm going to give a 50 000 foot
overview of this
we have become enamored obsessed
addicted
with psychopharmaceutical psychotropic
medications
meds for mental health issues and this
stems from
a a narrative that's been
given to us from doctors from medical
researchers and
most importantly from pharmaceutical
companies
and it's a myth that your brain
chemistry
is broken just like some people are born
five foot eight and some people are born
six foot two
some people are born with low serotonin
levels
some people are born with wacky dopamine
levels
and by some people maybe 25 to 50
freaking percent of the population
are born with altered brain chemistry
and here's the thing it allows us to
pass the buck on relationships on life
circumstances on
trauma on tragedy on systemic
issues like poverty and racism and
sexism and abusive relationships it
lasts
lets us pass the buck on all of that
and i go to the doctor and i say i can't
get these thoughts out of my head
and many doctors won't ask you what's
going on in your life
tell me about your childhood tell me
about your situation right now are you
safe they say yeah you may have altered
serotonin levels take this
and if you're just broken then you
didn't do anything wrong
your environment doesn't matter you
don't need to change anything
you just need to take your pills and
head on down the road right
we take so many psychotropic drugs as a
nation
that they are now lacing our drinking
water we peed them out in such mass
concentrations that they're in the water
that we drink
as one writer said we're awash in them
literally it's in our drinking water now
one in five u.s adults
i think it's one in four women are on
some sort of
psychotropic medication for anxiety for
depression fill in the blank fill in the
blank
and the numbers are continuing to
increase increase increase
and so to put that in perspective you
would think that
if we had stumbled on a quote-unquote
cure
for an illness for a disease for a
dysfunctional part of the human body
with one in five one in four people
taking these medications
that the numbers would go down they
would level off yet they're not
they are skyrocketing
and contrary to what you probably
believe and understand about how
research works and how the research
companies work
this isn't conspiracy nonsense blah blah
this is truth okay this isn't me
becoming like an internet influencer and
exposing this is just
factual okay most antidepressant studies
are paid for by pharmaceutical companies
and what that means is they own
the positive results of those studies
and they own the negative results of
those studies
and there's an economic incentive to
open a drawer and put the negative
studies in the drawer and shut it
they write the reports and present the
info at scientific journals
and here's the thing as we bag on higher
ed and we continue to defund colleges
college is way too expensive that's a
whole other conversation but as we
continue to defund the public good
the drug companies come in and they pick
up the slack
right so if we have a the university of
texas
or texas tech university and or texas a
m those are the three big kids from
where i'm from
rice university whatever
they hire their own scientists they do
their studies
they get grants from the federal
government from the state government
they use tuition dollars and they do a
study on something
and they put it out to the world and the
scientists bat it back and forth it's
called peer review they fight back and
forth over the results
and over time consensus comes to the top
and you have to put forth the the
studies that don't work
you have to put forth the studies that
do work which lead to new studies
when a pharmaceutical company runs those
things
they hire their own doctors they hire
their own doctor researchers medical
researchers
and then they do the studies and they
just need to
they need two to go right meaning they
can do a study
as johann hardy says in his book lost
connections which is an extraordinary
read
they can do a thousand studies 998 of
them
on a particular drug fail but two of
them
one of them with a population of 16 and
one of them a population of 100
and the population was 16 9 or 10 of
those
people for whatever reason showed some
trend towards positive this pill helped
them
and then in the study of 100
52 53 people got some help a little bit
of help here and there or maybe a lot of
help
right 998 studies said this drug has no
effects
or it may even be hurtful to you you
just need
two and the fda will stamp it and say
that that drug is good to go to market
and so here's the deal there is none
zero evidence for the low serotonin myth
that your brain produces low serotonin
some people are just born that way
and taking pills will raise it and fix
you
as dr monkreif says there's no evidence
there's a chemical imbalance in
depressed or anxious people's brains
the dsm this manual it's they call it
the psychiatric bible
it's a real thick book that's got all
the diagnosis
right you've got this you've got of that
you've got
this the manual that supposedly
determines a person's
you know diagnosis it's a mess it's a
big mess
and it almost exclusively never takes
into
environment context being at a really
controlled in work environment in an
abusive relationship
from a traumatic childhood in a system
that's
traumatizing you those things don't
matter
it's all about this diagnosis in your
brain
here's the truth almost
entirely we don't know why medications
work
i'm talking about psychotropic
medications we don't know why they work
we simply don't know
there are a number of people who have
incredibly
positive results and they do well it can
be from placebo
that could be from actual support and
help
and here's the deal i am one of them
i got bent low by anxiety
to the point that i was spinning out all
over the place and i took anxiety
medications for a season
and they worked awesome when i'd asked
my doctor
why do these work he'd say i don't know
they were originally designed
for congestion and people were reporting
hey i'm feeling less anxious and so
they are a whole class of drugs that are
prescribed off-label
off-brand but they worked
so here's the broad picture of
medication for folks who are dealing
with
major depressive disorders schizophrenia
bipolar
medication is magic it can be
extraordinary
particularly if you are doing it in
partnership with a great therapist with
good community groups
with skilled practitioners who know how
to teach you how to do relationships
and there are mental health issues again
like schizophrenia and bipolar some of
these things that have brain lesions
your brain is actually different
okay there are others like myself
who took anxiety medication for a season
and it worked wonders
and i took it for a season for a
specific season and i
partnered with a doctor whose goal was
to teach me how to take ownership of my
own health
he didn't tell me and i had two doctors
one holistic doctor and one
medical doctor neither of them told me i
was broken forever
neither of them told me hey your brain
is just
dysfunctional and it's always going to
be that way so you need to take medicine
the analogy i got was hey you were
training for a marathon and you stepped
off the curb
and really messed up your ankle and just
so happens your ankle's in your head
the alarms got going for so long and you
were eating trash and not sleeping and
isolating yourself
for so long that your
alarms just took over right they just
took over
and so for a season we're gonna ask you
to not run don't run
you need to go to a doctor and get your
leg taken care of
and then you're going to have to go
through rehab physical therapy
and then you're going to start walking
and then you can start jogging and then
you can start training for whatever race
you want to run again
and it just so happened all that stuff
was in my mind so for a season i took
some medication don't know how it works
my doctor would tell me he was honest
dude i don't know why my holistic doctor
gave me some supplements and she she
actually knew more about what those were
doing than the
pharmaceutical
and we started with the lowest possible
dose first this was my arrangement with
my doctor
you get your arrangement with your
doctor i'm not giving you medical advice
i'm telling you it worked for me
and then we decided hey we'll move up
later if we need to we never did
and he worked with me on a plan to get
off and stay off and that meant i had to
go see a counselor
that mean i had to be really honest with
my wife
that mean i had to be really intentional
about getting friends and getting
connected in my local community
a person is not a person without their
environment
it's one of my favorite quotes from
hari's work a person is not a person
without their environment
medication can help a person's body turn
off the alarms shut down the yelling and
screaming and fear responses and trauma
responses
and it did that for me and it's done
that for countless other people
but it is not the long-term solution
for most everybody
and so just like we just did with kelly
she is brave
and she is strong and i'm so proud of
her
for having courage for being a great mom
being a great partner
and for recognizing i'm not doing well
but seriously seriously
the goal is not to be on medication
forever the goal is to
use meds as a bridge to get your life
back so kelly
thank you so much for your call for
being brave
no shame no failure
strength i'm proud of you for doing the
work that you need to do to get well
this is step one step two is going to be
boundaries relationships and connection
and finding ways you can control what
you can control in your little bitty
universe
i'm proud of you all right let's go to
kevin in keene new hampshire
kevin what is up hey dr john
thanks so much for taking my call hey
thank you for calling what can i do to
help
sure so um my
wife and mother-in-law um haven't spoken
really
since about february march of this year
um and this is the first kind of holiday
season without
them talking to each other i want to try
to be
the best husband i can for my wife and i
i know that my own mental capacity i try
to fix things all the time so i'm trying
to see
what's the best thing i can do how's the
best way i can be supportive for her
so why aren't they talking
um well it kind of goes back a little
ways but
my my mother-in-law struggles with
alcohol abuse
this kind of spring and summer
she went into a couple rehab facilities
i think about i can't remember how many
different ones but
the first one she was kind of forced
into by my sister-in-law
and because she came over to our house
when we
set the boundary of not having any
alcohol in the house and she brought
alcohol
into our house so we kind of cut off
communication there because we have
little ones yeah you don't need you did
the absolute right thing there i'm proud
of you for that
good for you thank you good for you um
so bring me to how can i help you guys
right now
is is your wife just struggling
crumbling under that broken relationship
or how are you caught in the middle of
this
so we've we've gone and we've helped her
um set up a couple counseling sessions
with a christian counselor
um it's been going good but i i noticed
around thanksgiving that it was eating
her it was eating at her a little bit
um that she wasn't seeing her mom um i
don't know if it was
a part of guilt um i don't know if it
was just
missing her um but i know that it was
it was eating her and um and i know that
christmas is coming up around the corner
yep um so i just i want to be as
supportive as i can
so kevin you are husband of the year
good for you brother for
just wanting to be there for your wife
and for recognizing you're an advice
giver and a fixer and that's not what's
going to help in this moment awesome
alright so here's what your wife is
feeling all of that
she is grieving a fantasy that is dead
and gone
and the fantasy is most people's
wish what should be is that our moms are
there for us
they're whole they're connected they
show up to a warm house with a fire and
great food over thanksgiving
and your wife's mother is in rehab
again is disconnected because she
brought alcohol into your home in
violation of the boundaries you drew for
her
so your wife is grieving she is sad her
fantasy is
busted up she misses her mom and that
just sucks
and then you are astute man christmas
comes on the same day every year so here
it comes
so here's what i want you to do today
i want you to tell your your wife that
you want to have a conversation about
christmas
and her mom and you want to do it in a
couple of days
and i want you to ask your wife to write
your mom a letter
that she's i mean write her mom a letter
that she's never gonna send
a letter about how she feels a letter
about how she misses her
a letter about what she's missing with
her grandkids
and a letter that says i hope that we
can reconcile someday but not now
and i want your wife to write that
letter and then she's going to read it
to you
she's going to read it to you so she's
going to be vulnerable and open with you
she's going to read that letter to you
and then you guys are going to make a
plan for christmas
together and your wife is going to
inform that
of course you know where you want it to
head where you want it to be
but she's going to inform the season
and it's not going to include her mom
and you're going to hold her hands
during this process and just look her in
the eye and say this sucks and i'm sorry
and what you're doing for her is you're
creating space you are moving
things out of the way so your wife can
have space to grieve and just be
sad and here's the thing kevin this may
just be a sad
season this may be the season where the
fantasy the the the
the luster the shine is is wearing off
and this is just going to be what this
is going to be at least for 2020
maybe for 2021 maybe forever
and so by writing a a letter to her mom
she gets all these thoughts that are
weighing her down
she gets them out of her head and on
paper they're directed to a person
and by saying them to you y'all are
going to have a connection a
vulnerability connection an
intimacy connection and she's going to
say the words out loud
mom here's how i feel
here's what you're missing here's where
i'm pissed off here's where i
hate what you have done and here's where
i hope deeply that we can come back
together someday
and then y'all are going to plan out
what christmas is going to be and then
you're going to have to make space for
your wife just to be sad this season
she'll be joyful but this is going to be
a season for sadness
and what we're hopeful that we're going
to plan we're going to hope that that
plan will help
but you're going to have to work on you
this season kevin because your wife's
just going to have to grieve this
so the greatest thing you can do is
create space give her the opportunity to
tell her you're there for
tell that you love when you're
supporting her take a deep breath drop
your shoulders and then head on into the
season
kevin i'm i'm proud of you you're a good
husband good for you
and let's get through this all of us
together
let's go to dead stick one more call
let's go to michelle and san luis obispo
what's going on michelle hi john how are
you
i am doing all right how about you i'm
doing all right
all right how can i help today um
i was when i was younger i was sexually
abused by my brothers
by both of them and um
i'm so sorry my mom knew what was going
on
and um my brothers
they've apologized to me about it later
in life and my mom admitted that she
knew what was going on but she
didn't know what to do but um my issue
is
um what i still one of my brothers
that continued on he um
has been watching child pornography and
um
and he's done really messed up things
with
my dog and he's also basically assaulted
me three years ago
um and i ended up having a miscarriage
forward um but
i'm sorry i'm like i can't have to catch
my breath
i've really you know i only have one mom
and i really miss her
and i haven't walked home in like a year
i moved out of my house
it was my parents house and i just don't
know
where to go from here or like
yeah this is a lot michelle
so this this is awful
and evil on a bunch of different levels
here
and i'm gonna speak real directly and
honest with you okay
okay are you hearing me yes
i'm gonna be real direct with you number
one
right when this call is over you will
hang up the phone
and you will call the police on your
brother for watching child pornography
period okay okay
that isn't a negotiable thing we are
going to sense we
going gonna call somebody here and so
you can beat us to the punch
but when i know about something about
children being hurt
children being exploited or abused i'm
making that call and i expect every
person
whether it's your mom your brother your
dad your husband i don't care who it is
to make that call and so right when we
get off this phone you're gonna make
that call
okay okay this is about you re
reclaiming control about what's right
and you taking quote unquote the power
back in your life
number two your brother apologize your
other brother apologized to you
for sexually assaulting you as kids
good for him that does not mean that he
has permission to waltz back into your
life
that you owe him any sort of
relationship any sort of connection
anything like that
you michelle are in control of the story
you michelle are in control of what
happens next
okay okay and for somebody who's been
abused in the way you have been
your whole life people have taken from
you and taken and taken and taken
and you're gonna have to get with a
professional
immediately okay immediately
to begin walking back that trauma when
it comes to your mom
your mom committed what i think is one
of the most egregious evils a parent can
do
which is she let her child be hurt
and just watched it happen
yeah i'm not going to judge your mom
because i don't know what her life
history is
i don't know what evils were done to her
i know there was something super toxic
going on in your home
for this to be going on the way it has
been
and i'm sure we could talk for hours as
you unpacked your childhood
but what your mom did to you is wrong
she not only abandoned you she set you
up for a
lifetime of hurt and trauma and
pain and evil
and of course you miss your mom but you
miss the fantasy of your mom more than
you miss your mom
yeah i do i miss i miss like having a
mom and
you know what when i always pictured
like a mom to be you know
for me and here's what really sucks
michelle i told you i was gonna tell you
the truth
you didn't get that mom you deserved
that mom
you should have got that mom and you
didn't get that mom
and so as you sit in the ash of that and
you've been sitting in these ashes for a
long time
you just thought those ashes were trees
and grass they weren't
they were grit and concrete
and blood-stained dirt
ash and now what you have to do
the work you have to do is to get with a
professional
today and this call is happening between
us in the morning
and so you've got all day to find
somebody
go find a professional who's going to
walk a journey with you and your journey
is going to be longer than most
i have a question john so yeah my mom
she also
she apologized she said excellent
good for her i'm glad she apologized
good for her and i'm all about
redemption
i'm all about people changing and
growing and moving on
but she hurts you in a way that your
soul
and your brain and your body are going
to be recovering for years and years and
years
because if you can't trust your mom to
show up and stop evil who
in god's name can you trust
right yes right i don't know a lot about
the world but i know the world's a
crummy place sometimes and that's why
moms and dads are there
to protect children
and your mom didn't show up
when my brother when he assaulted me
three years ago when he physically
assaulted me for years ago
my mom i called the police and i was
leaving at my parents house at that time
good for her good hey listen listen
listen
i want you to hear what you're doing
which is classic
abuse survivor behavior you're trying to
make everyone else okay
you're trying to come up with excuses
and reasons why you shouldn't hurt so
bad
why they're not quite as bad as it seems
on paper
and here's the thing 20 years ago 30
years ago
maybe your mom is a radically different
human being she's a vigilante now
she has high support
she is take no crap off anybody
burn all of them down who hurt my baby
girl maybe that's why she is awesome
good for her you still have healing to
do
that you cannot do if you are tethered
to her right now
that doesn't mean that your
relationship's over forever
but it does mean for a season there's
got to be some space and separation
because
you don't even know what healthy love
looks like
feels like you don't know what that
sidewalk feels like when you walk on it
and it's totally firm
and it's safe you don't know what green
grass and trees feel like and smell like
your body has never experienced a flower
because you've been living in ash
and so today you're going to call the
police on your brother
for continuing to perpetuate child
pornography today you're going to call a
therapist and say
for the first time in a long time i'm
going to take care of me
i need help and what's going to happen
over time is you're going to work to
establish relationships
with the women in your community that
you trust
that will become surrogate moms to you
that will lean into your life
that will honor you and will cherish you
and will protect you
will give you wisdom give you safety
and then when you get tethered into
those relationships then you will be
safe enough
to maybe maybe
invite your mom out for coffee and say
hi how are you
because you're going to know strength
then you're going to know safety then
that you have never felt
never known brother's job is to burn the
world down for his little sister
not to abuse her
the other brother's job
is to knock the teeth out of the older
brother who abuses my sister
not to join in and the mom's job
is to burn it all down for my daughter
not to turn my head the other way
michelle i'm
so sorry you deserved more than this
and i don't mean this trite and i don't
mean this disrespectfully
there is healing on the other side of
this and it's going to be a
hard exhausting road which means you got
to get people around you that you trust
and will care for you
but there is healing on the other way
and it starts with that phone call the
9-1-1
it starts with that phone call to a
therapist
it starts with you finding a friend or
another woman in your community where
you work at your church
letting her know here's what happened to
me here's my childhood and i need
someone to lean on in the next
year in the next two years because i got
a long road to walk
so as you make this journey michelle as
you make these calls as you start
leaning into the
the future here we're here for you
shoot me an email give me a call we'll
have you back on the show talk about how
your progress is going
make no mistake it's going to be ugly
and messy your mom doesn't get a vote
your brothers don't get a vote your dad
didn't get a vote
none of those people who hurt you get a
vote
it's time you put on your oxygen mask
michelle and start taking care of you
and it starts today thank you so much
for calling so as we wrap up today's
show
i want to go back to a 1967 classic
on the greatest voices in the history of
earth
miss nina simone most beautiful voices
beautiful truth teller crass hilarious
gorgeous
she wrote a song called keeper of the
flame
and in this 1967 classic she writes
i'm the keeper of the flame my torch of
love lights his name
ask no pity beg my shame i'm the keeper
of the flame
played with fire and i was burned give a
heart but i was spur and all these times
i've yearned
just to have my love returned years have
passed by that spark still remains true
love can't die
it smolders in flame when the fire is
burning off and the angels call my name
dying love will leave no doubt i'm the
keeper of the flame
ah make your day better and go listen to
some nina simone
this has been the dr john daloni show